bon voilà c'est pas mal on garde ça si
graphique l'excision
sa lancée
le rapport
on voit la regarde la noce là c'est beau
parce qu'à pas deux courriers au sol sa
vue
ouais je sais pas
le bateau
tiens
ok
ce tournant
et
ce ne sera pas pour la ducasse
la série
on va aller un peu plus loin pour le
frère dessous de l'âge du mois
pas assez en forme pour moi j'écoute je
regarde la voir en doc qui faisons
hayes alors de l'hélico
et à l'ombre des taux
pour nous ce soir retrouvez lead delà du
champ
70 rosso bizarre
on serait plus triste un plan directeur
qui sert
bazire
pari foot
bon encontre pasqua la bolivie va les
arrêter
à circa ce matin tiens regarde
bref à merde
l'art et le fado
par rapport à hier
seuls ceux qui n'ont pas qu'il faut pas
nombre devant sa particularité
français de sortir de st dans libération
la soir du bal catalan chance à l'équipe
dans le sens où tu veux
on s'emballe à ressorts d'un adroit sur
le retour à la vie normale
il retrouvera pour un peu plus dans les
jambes on prêt que l'on développe hors
du champ voilà voilà
aulas aura lieu salle ailleurs dans le
fatah savalas rythme-là thorgal et
lumière verte
ils sont descendus sans doute
ah voilà yahoo
papa lé là arriver là
montrer que les gens auront dans le
champêtre possible voilà les panneaux
solaires quoi bon en cultiver des
panneaux solaires
rupture de prénationale
ils arrosent
je passe quoi on fasse comme ça on passe
et on s'arrête voulait faire quoi la hat
enjeux métier je tourne je me courbe à
droite et qui avait soulevé par habitant
y fit la texture voilà
assuré
dormez
pas dans la partie blanche
bref
bon
m
un couple un don
embarras
c'est génial voilà si brive à l'arrêt
allez on s'emballe vanrooy devants face
au soleil
voilà comme ça vous allez l'avoir par
les intéressés eux c'est leur sélection
voilà c'est dit c'est chiant voilà ne se
fait pas prier les peut partir voilà
voilà maintenant